you don't believe him Batman
Batman is an urban legend
no it is not these on here I'm kicking
your butt come on break it up
I'm the green arrow yeah I'll say
morning
hey cakes are perfect this time babe
okay what's wrong love you you are as
despicable as they come you are
dangerous and you are clearly crazy Alex
please I know the world looks one way to
you but we're sisters
hey everybody its charlie we got brand
new flash arrow Elseworlds crossover
footage to break down we have the first
footage of bat woman and then talking
about batman in a really big way in the
universe I think this is actually the
first time that someone has directly
referenced Batman so I'll try to explain
what's going on we have a whole bunch of
preview pictures to break down to
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a DC related
comment on the video most important
thing first we have the intro footage of
bat woman while you have the voiceover
dialogue from Barry talking about Batman
with a couple other characters most
notably Oliver who believes that Batman
is just an urban myth Barry is the one
that believes that Batman is real then
they cut with slightly different footage
as you go inside Arkham Asylum remember
this is still I think it's supposed to
be earth one there's a prison break
that's going on that woman is there to
stop it so Barry shows up but it's after
the Freaky Friday situation has happened
and they've swapped lives so he's
wearing the green arrow costume he and
Cisco say that's definitely not Batman
so cisco has joined up with them but
there's some preview images of cisco
doing very different stuff in this
universe but I think all the footage
we've seen so far is after the life
swapping has gone down you go through
Arkham they try to lay in a couple
Batman's specific character references
like you see that person jump off the
ledge there and laugh like the Joker I
don't know that that's a version of the
Joker they include the Joker's laugh so
they just want you to think Batman
villains but it's a prison break that
woman shows up to try and take them down
it seems like Oliver and Barry maybe
come to Gotham to try and find Batman to
get his help but the producers explained
this is what's going on with Batman so
we're talking about the
one version of Batman they go to Gotham
Oliver isn't totally sure that he's real
but the producers say that he's been
missing for the last three years I don't
know why anybody else hasn't referenced
it anywhere else in the air overs
because even in Star City in Central
City Bruce wayne/batman would be iconic
figures even if people didn't know that
he was secretly Batman Bruce Wayne
billionaire missing for the last three
years would be very noteworthy within
Arkham Asylum
dr. destiny who's supposed to be one of
the main villains of the crossover is
the actual person that does the life
swapping so whatever book that's
involved in trying to swap things back
like you see black suit Superman holding
it here dr. destiny played by Jeremy
Davies is the person that starts all
these problems it's not really clear how
big of a character he's going to be
after this or if it's gonna spin into
some bigger crisis on Infinite Earths
situation but whatever his deeper
machination czar it gains the attention
of the monitor who's kind of like The
Watcher inside the DC Universe if you've
never Millie with the monitors they
don't really take action in the affairs
of lesser beings they just watch it
unfold so the fact that one does get
involved means that it's a very serious
situation but the producers explained
that what happens is is that Kara is one
of the few people that knows what's
going on like her mind hasn't been
messed with and she's still in her
regular body her life hasn't changed
that much but everything around her has
changed Oliver and Barry both have their
minds and their wits about them but
their entire lives have changed it is
sort of callback to the flash versus
arrow episode I don't know how long it's
gonna last but they do come to blows
they fight each other car is the one
that sort of cuts the tension and brings
them to their senses like look remember
we need to fight we need to figure out
what's going on here that's when I think
they're in Gotham trying to deal with
the loss of Batman and trying to unravel
the mystery behind dr. destiny in this
mystery book thus far the producers have
not said a whole lot about what's going
on with Superman Lois Lane in black
costume Superman because we see two
versions of them fighting each other so
I have no idea how crazy battle royale
this is going to get but it all revolves
around the MacGuffin of this strange
book that you see the monitor holding in
all the promos so we'll find out a
little bit more about that as we get
more footage I'm expecting the next
trailer they drop because they've
introduced most of the characters to be
a Superman trailer because he's one of
the few main characters we haven't seen
yet and it seems like a pretty big
trailer to drop like here's Superman
he's returned in our first look at Lois
Lane in the DC TV universe they haven't
explained what's going on with STAR Labs
here but I'm assuming it has something
to do with black suit Superman because
look at Alex here she has like this
really weird looking haircut but she has
a black Superman symbol on her chest
here and whatever's going on she's
calling Cara crazy
so if maybe there's some life swapping
situation maybe she's an outlier or
maybe when everything gets switched you
have a more hardcore version of Superman
that's working with Oliver because it's
STAR Labs
so the Oliver version of the flash would
be associated with STAR Labs the way
that Barry has been on the flash TV show
for the last several years but without
seeing more footage it implies that
black suits Superman in this continuity
however reality has changed is teaming
up with the Oliver version of the flash
which does sound badass flash and
Superman team-up but it's like the
hardcore Stephen Amell version and you
have the black suit Tyler hoechlin
Superman version you watch all this
footage and you kind of see why they
decided not to include all of the
Legends characters the producers
clarified that they really just wanted
to do the manes of all the TV shows and
it's easier to do that with like the
single character leaves but the problem
with legends is is that it's an ensemble
show so when you include one of them you
kind of have to include all them but
they did say that one of the legends
would cameo in the final night of the
crossover which is gonna be the
Supergirl episode on Tuesday night
they didn't say which one it would be so
my assumption is is that it's either
gonna be Constantine because of all the
crazy doctor destiny big stuff that's
going on or it's gonna be Sarah just
because she's kind of like the main lead
even though technically it's an ensemble
show they dropped a whole bunch of
pictures too so we see Cisco and
whatever his new life is it seems like
he's some minor crime boss or he's just
got a really dirty shady neo-noir
looking office in the back of a bar or
something like that Jimmy Olsen seems
like he's way more hardcore this is the
first real look at the monitor when he's
not all photoshopped out like he is on
the posters like this is what he'll look
like in the actual episodes I couldn't
wait when I heard that they were gonna
do
book accurate costume you never really
know what that's gonna end up looking
like but for the most part the
arrowverse does do pretty good costumes
what'll happen though is is that the
regular episodes this week next week is
the 100th episode of the flash zoom is
coming back for sure
maybe reverse flash then the week after
that is all the crossover stuff will get
a whole bunch more trailers I'll remind
everybody about what's going on when we
get new stuff but there's also a really
big rumor that we're gonna get the
Avengers 4 trailer later this week for
Black Friday it's just a rumor
so if I hear anything more about that I
will let you guys know if for some
reason it does not drop then it'll
probably just drop either next week or
the week after that but either way click
here to rewatch that crazy new Deadpool
Christmas trailer and click here for
that last really big Aquaman trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]